good morning belief nation today's
message is live your dream over to you
Nipsey Hussle success to me I say it a
lot is just being able to do what you
love to do and support yourself also
live your dream and do what you got to
do every day so I'm successful my
offices I don't sell dope I don't go to
work and I do music and I love to do it
and that's all I had to do with my time
I think most people don't live their
dream because one they're too worried
about what other people think of them
and they let those opinions prevent them
from doing the thing that they really
want to do and two you're just afraid
because it's not safe because it's not
practical because you don't know how
it's gonna make sense and so because you
can't figure out all those pieces then
you never take action and both of those
are probably the worst decisions that
you can make because when you look back
on your life those will be the biggest
regrets and you'll always have this
thing that you say I wish I tried this
and if if that's what you're thinking
right now then you need to go out and do
it I was talking with Jason my
videographer here and he has this dream
of going to Europe and shooting this
spec project and the people around him
are saying that he's crazy not me but
the other people around him say that
he's crazy and that this is a waste of
time and a waste of money you should do
the smart thing the same thing and stay
here and film it here and like why are
you off doing this crazy spec work who's
ever gonna pay you for this what's the
point and looking at those people you
know have they done what he wants to do
have they accomplished the things that
he wants to accomplish the answer is no
and they're not betting on their dreams
and they're not betting on themselves
that they're not trying to improve
themselves AG Waffen chase something big
so why would he listen to them for their
advice on what to do if anything he
would want to do the exact opposite of
what they recommend cuz he does not want
our life like theirs and you need to
reflect the same way on your life on
your business and the things that you
need to make a decision on the people
who are giving you guidance do you want
life like theirs that they're living
right now and if not then do the
opposite of what they're telling you to
do even though a lot of what they're
saying is out of love right the people
talking to Jason care about him it's not
to screw him over they're not trying to
beat him down they care about him they
genuinely want him to be a successful
happy person they just don't have the
context they don't know how to help him
get to where he wants to go and so
they're doing they're seeing his life
through their filters and I've seen that
I wanted to do what I would never go and
so I'm gonna show love by telling him
what I would do which is the wrong
advice because again they've never gone
that far we've been talking about Steve
Jobs seemingly all day after that early
conversation talking about the
connecting the dots and how you can't
connect the dots looking forward only
looking backwards and so the thing that
you're doing right now may seem crazy
because you don't know how it's gonna
make sense because you can't connect
those dots looking forward but looking
backwards it makes total sense Steve
Jobs when he was a university dropped
out wasn't enjoying the classes and how
many people would actually had the
courage to drop out of a safe path to go
off and do something without a
predetermined plan right like I don't
know where I'm gonna go but I know that
this is not the right thing for me most
people don't have the courage to do that
he dropped out to go learn about fonts
and calligraphy seemingly the least
practical thing for him to know ever
like what do you do with that knowledge
and everybody thought that he was nuts
and he was crazy
fast forward a number of years he's part
of Apple
he's helping build this computer company
he's a co-founder and the thing that
made the Apple Computer is different in
the early years was the fonts they had
unique and different fonts where all the
other computers didn't have it and that
came because he dropped in on those
university classes and he had no way of
knowing early on in his life when he
dropped out and dropped in in those
class that he would eventually start a
computer company and become one of the
richest people in the world in part
because of learning what he was learning
in this class looking back it makes
total sense but looking forward
he just looks crazy in everybody's eyes
and he may not have known himself right
that's the biggest challenge when you
don't know yourself if for how it's
going to work
out but you still go forward and do it
because you can't connect the dots
looking forward only backwards so if
you're in that position now where the
people around your telling you this is
crazy the stupid don't do it and you're
also thinking it's not practical it's
not safe I don't know how it's gonna
succeed you can mitigate the risk but
you have to still go and do it so you
don't live with regret goal chased and
live your dream
so the question today today is what's
something that you really want to do but
you're afraid up and you're holding
yourself back what is that
leaving the comments below really
curious to find out thank you guys so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of Enter